you live in this small quaint town does
it ever get a little too small and
quaint for you do you ever wish that you
could uh you need to do you ever feel
like I need to bust out of here there
are too many thatched roofs too many eel
pies cooling on a shelf do you ever feel
like I've got to get out of here uh yeah
definitely like if you live in a small
town you always kind of get that but you
know with uh Oxford being so close you
kind of have that kind of I can go and
be in a place where there are things
that actually happen right right
Abington where we have a we have a town
crier what what you're kidding you have
a town crier we have a Time crying and
does he read the news does he ever say
any news events or is it just to tell
you the time it's usually going to tell
you like oh there's an arts and crafts
fair on does he start with hear ye hear
ye yeah yeah he's absolutely
textbook so he says hear ye hear ye
and then he says there's an arts and
crafts fair uh over on you know
Paddington piddle Road
uh in in 10 minutes that's the kind of
thing he says yeah wow don't forget to
scrape the dung out your shoes Okay Okay
does he ever say anything salacious like
here ye hear ye uh I hear uh you know
Colleen uh havenhurst is pretty fast and
loose with the fellas
but we can feed that information I'm
sorry I'm just thinking more of like a
TMZ type oh yeah or or what if he's
having a bad day and he's like my wife's
so hard
I think my wife is stepping out on me
if you see that let me know what
what do you think uh an L.A Town cry
would say I think it's man it depends on
where you are in L.A yeah I think it'd
be a lot of hear ye hear ye someone's
overdoing it with the Botox and she
knows who she is and then literally 175
000 women will think it's them yeah our
town cries are essentially people in
town just crying yeah you're doing the
right thing by staying there uh have you
have you traveled to Los Angeles before
I I've not been to Los Angeles but I
have been to California I worked up in
uh North California uh summer camp it
was actually at the same time so we kind
of had a bit of an exchange so when you
came to Oxford I was over in California
yes I think it's a one one in one out
kind of situation yes what happened was
I was I was invited my my cohorts may
not know this but I was invited to speak
uh at Oxford it was a high honor and I
went there uh my wife and I uh we
actually we brought our kids as well
they didn't come to the talk but my wife
came Liza came and it was uh thrilling
because the students were very smart and
uh fantastic crowd I had a great time
but you said that you specifically left
the country when you heard I was coming
smart but I think it was more I think it
was kind of an exchange because I think
we're of quite similar compress
complexions and I think I think it's
probably a fire risk to have us both
there at the same time
because you guys are like too much
Tinder it's too much yeah we might yeah
we just combust are you uh are you a
ginger I can't really quite you are a
ginger okay I blend into the background
as well as my jumper yeah it's also my
uh entire being you see that's why we're
we're different
um I'm of course of Irish descent your
English uh and we both have the same
complexion I never ever have worn an
orange sweater in my life because I felt
like I can't I'm a ginger you just said
I'm going for it Balls to the walls good
and it looks good on you oh yeah it's
got to go all in ginger balls to the
wall
excuse me oh wait a minute I've done
that okay I've done that Jack and it's a
mistake I did that I did Ginger balls to
the wall it was uh it was in a bus
station in Newark and uh again not worth
getting into but uh is there a little
plaque
well opponent's balls were here yes I've
asked that a plaque B uh I was gonna say
erected but uh I'm not going to there's
a sack on a plaque yeah okay okay this
is a wonderful that's the EE Cummings
poem that was never published